as a woman what don't men understand  about women  oh my God you see what I'm saying here  you're like all right so it helps you  understand women  and women okay  let's say first and foremost just it's  just especially doing the show it's just  crazy how much girls like cap and I just  think a lot of people cat for 30 and  overcrowd that means a lot okay  um I'm like I also think it's important  to understand like that women are  hypergamous like I think that's  important and the things that you need  to do to be attractive to women like and  I don't give dating advice like that's  not my thing you know but I think it's  important that men understand that you  know women like they don't like nice  guys they tend to like guys that have a  backbone like that sort of thing yeah